as a side note for the dudes who are
like considering getting a girl into
their into their business like you have
to have objectively been willing to pick
that girl of all people to do that role
I think happens more often is guys are
like man I want to involve my wife in
the business who doesn't really like
business and then they pull them in they
don't give them the respect because
maybe that's not warranted because they
don't have the Acumen for it or whatever
and then they give them kind of a peon
roll which that doesn't necessarily
breed even more respect so that they can
be like quote involved the role has to
be the role that you would pick for that
person like if you didn't have the
relationship like if we weren't together
I would still want Layla basically
running all the companies she's great at
it it's why we do well we just get the
benefit of the fact that like we're also
married